[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment
of harry potter theory in today's video
we're going to be discussing sirius
black remus lupin
peter pettigrew and the moment in the
prison of azkaban
when wormtail feared for his life during
the 1993-1994 school year
sirius black plotted to kill peter
pettigrew the man who framed him
in an effort to avenge the deaths of
harry's parents
lily and james potter pettigrew was of
course the secret keeper that went sour
disclosing the location of the potter
cottage to voldemort and it was his
actions that resulted in their deaths
sirius black was the initial choice for
secret keeper
but sirius thinking that voldemort might
target him
suggested they choose pettigrew instead
the following excerpt from sirius
addresses this lily and james only made
you secret keeper because i suggested it
i thought it was the perfect plan
voldemort would be sure to come after me
would never dream that he's a weak
talentless thing like you it must have
been the finest moment of your miserable
life
telling voldemort he could hand him the
potters after betraying the potters
sirius went after peter
but only ended up being blamed for more
of peter's crimes
successfully being framed by him the
fact that sirius suggested pettigrew be
secret keeper
only to have him betray them and then be
blamed for his crimes
ate away at sirius for the duration of
his time at azkaban
this meant that he had years to plan his
revenge and he landed on the decision
that he would kill peter the second he
got out
during the 1993-1994 school year
sirius black pursued this very objective
in an effort to avenge the deaths of his
friends
he escaped azkaban and eventually found
himself in a shrieking shack
along with fellow marauder remus lupin
who was teaching at hogwarts
and ex-marauder pettigrew in rat form
this was sirius's opportunity to finally
kill pettigrew
and remus who was present at the time
decided that he wanted in
you don't understand he would have
killed me sirius then you should have
died
died rather than betray your friends as
we would have done for you
you should have realized if voldemort
didn't kill you we would
goodbye peter at this point the pair
point their wands at him
shall we kill him together yes i think
so
said lupin grimly now obviously they
don't end up killing him
so we don't get to see how it's done but
what i wonder is
what spell would they have used the pair
were killing him together
and nevada kadavra certainly doesn't
require two people
so what was their course of action going
to be i certainly don't think that swift
and easy was their preferred option
particularly as petaku had wronged to
them on so many levels
for this reason i'm of the impression
that they may have used transmography
and
torture a spell similar to grucio with
the exception that the victim will
eventually die
it's much worse than nevada kadavra but
it avoids unforgivable status
for reasons beyond me in addition to
wanting to draw out patago's death
i think that remus and sirius also
committed the act together
to share the blame in the event that
they were caught at this stage
sirius was a guilty man and pettigrew
was not so if the ministry determined
that pettigrew was in fact
not a death eater then they would have
been on the hook for killing him
did you guys ever think about this if
you enjoyed the content please like the
video
and subscribe until next time you're a
wizard harry
you